I feel like in order to move forward you
have to deal with things you can't just
hide them it's important for me to be a
passionate performer and a passionate
singer well I've always been a control
freak from a very young age lead
motivation watch the top 10 with believe
nation what's that believe nation it's
Evan I believe in you and this channel
is designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a woman who went
from having her father leave her when
she was 2 years old starting to sing
when she was 4 years old to becoming one
of the most influential people on the
planet and one of the greatest selling
artists of all time
she's Adele and here's my take on her
top 10 days of success
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be in control but you are very much
in control of your career Society it's
not an easy thing to do how did you
learn how to do that tell me about the
process of learning how to be in control
well I've always been a control freak
from a very young age and I would have
credit my management for that like when
I'm like really really tired and I'm
like can you just decide that I can't
bothered right now but no saying up to a
5:00 a.m. until you understand
everything and then you can give me a
yes or a No
with a good reading set and stuff at
that so definitely my maths good
management yeah oh no my management a
great light and also like they want me
to make the decisions on everything
small things big things where vijai mean
so that and it's my music and I'm the
artist
so why someone in a boardroom who's
never written a record in their lives
should be making decisions for me no we
are the artists and we should be able to
decide in every aspect rule number two
don't let people rush you the success of
nineteen is like kind of shocked
everyone involved with it like because
like I said that I started for no money
in the UK do I mean there was nothing
riding on it and I think if I sold like
ten thousand records worldwide then
they'd be really rushing me that's a
little quick let's do another record
like he didn't make much of an impact so
you can follow it up with whatever but
because that I've because of the success
I feel like people to like take your
time and I find that debut artists and
bands get really frightened about losing
a little niche that they've created for
themselves and they'll get scared that
people are gonna forget about them and
they rush their album and then kind of
constantly want to stay in the limelight
and even when they're not performing
they'll go on like tacky chat shows and
tacky game shows and stuff like that and
inter-site and and sell out and do like
adverts and stuff like that was I think
you're only as good as your net expect
cord and I don't care if the whole world
forgets about me if it takes me five
years to write a second album if you
come back with that like amazing single
and wicked record and people will
remember you rule number three be
passionate
[Music]
someone like you
[Music]
well my favorite thing is I'm very very
passionate and it's important for me to
be a passionate performer and a
passionate singer and I am passionate
about anything but the things that got
you going in my life
rule number four don't let things hold
you back I heard this question of how
does one move forward well right right
and the captured this feeling for me of
how do you deal with people and places
are still in your heart yeah but they're
not in your life yeah what did you gain
from exploring that just it really need
to move on I think I feel like lorded to
move forward you have to deal with
things you can't just hide them and I
feel like my whole life either swept
things under the carpet and stuff like
that and whereas by dealing with it all
which is because I was a parent and I
only have so much capacity for drunk now
I had to do those things and it was
great because it made me realize
actually that all of the things I was
holding on to good and bad they weren't
that good and they weren't that bad and
it was just life you know so it's sort
of it made it a lot easier rule number
five don't let haters change you they
live in the airbrushed era
yeah people augment themselves and have
you had any pressure has anybody talked
to you about you know we want to change
your hair we want to do this to you or
it no no no never I think that's because
I think and I started an indie label and
it's not really about that kind of thing
you know they don't really think like a
major that much and then when I did
science a major record company in the
rest of America of Columbia I was you
know I was already quite established in
in England as in like known for putting
my foot down and not letting anyone be
like very my face and so now I haven't
um and also like I'm not going to not
just because like people more people
know me like people like you know like
want to be rude about me I'm gonna be
fat and stuff like that then like that's
kind of makes me not want to change even
more do you I mean because because I
just like giving in and also I don't
know these people like being all but
about me yeah I mean I never gonna meet
them they were anonymous on YouTube I
don't care rule number six go with your
instincts
accordingly Malibu was a pretty
isolating really when were in the studio
no one who wasn't on the record was
allowed into the room it was just me the
band rhythmic and the engineers and we
could have been in 1950 or we could have
been in 2019 I mean it was just all
about the song and about the music and I
had absolutely no idea what was going on
in the charts or what new videos had to
come out you know I was completely
clueless and it was all just about kind
of creating a vibe and going with our
instinct which I felt very very lucky
and fortunate to be able to do a record
like that so early on in my career so
that was really quite inspirational rule
number seven really care about people
what did I see my vocal doctor hmm he
did my surgery not nothing's wrong just
for him to be like it's all right yeah
that's it that's exciting
American cancel loads and loathing kinds
of a whole - why did cancel holds well
but I hold true is another global tour
last time but you know the letting
people down like that it was I didn't
play enough shows last time so people
were like flying in for shows hotels
anniversary is that two years in advance
that's a lot of fishermen and cancelling
their shows broke my heart
it really did like letting them down and
seeing them out of my tour bus really
upset and it being more than the cost of
a ticket and being the cost of a fly in
a journey really like I still haven't
forgiven myself for it so the idea and I
don't have a big enough window time to
tall enough like my kids gonna start
school I have a small window at all it's
gonna be an under play because I haven't
told and it's like I don't let them down
so you knows the pressure of that I mean
yeah I haven't booked anything them
though at the same time I don't like
cancelling shows because it takes a lot
for me to give up my money to go and see
someone play live so I really appreciate
the fact that these people you know sort
of spend their monthly sort of treat
allowance coming to see me and so I was
really really guided about having to let
all of those people down rule number
eight have integrity
kindest thing like when you're new and
you've got all these people who you
think know better than you and I'm not
the only one I'm sure they do know
better we're not subways but no one
knows what's best for one person apart
from that person and how it makes them
feel we're very at like I don't believe
in it
happen if they're doing something
everyone else thinks they should do I
think it's about integrity and stuff
like that you know which all of us have
and all of us use rule number nine
collaborate it was a very conscious
decision I made to work with as many
people as possible and my first record
I'd say about 85% of it was all me and
you know I had some of them songs for
when I was 16 and I'm very limited at
the moment when it comes to being a
musician Joe I mean I'm not as musically
academic as Paul Epworth is and as
fraser t smith and ryan and Dan Wilson
so I don't know four chords so if I've
written how record again on my own it
would have sounded like 19 and that's my
biggest fear was making the same worth
would again and I find I'm reading this
missive of my own material and I throw
ideas away really really easily which i
think is a bad thing but when I work
with someone else I throw it and they
catch it and then they kind of turn it
into something that ends up really
really working so I think going down the
line it'll be more and more that I'll be
collaborating with other people and rule
number ten the last one before a very
special bonus clip is make an impact
what is it like to know that so many
people love what you do it's incredible
that people who lay me into their lives
again but yeah I was worried I missed my
window and I was worried that the world
moved on so much in so many different
ways she needn't have worried but word
got out that Adele was back hello social
media exploited me
I had no idea how powerful social media
was until this week and up to now I
already get it now I thought I would be
freaking out let's go out over the
school and let's die it's actually you
can't actually be old school in a world
where social media is in charge of
pretty much the world hello it started
with this it's me a 30-second TV ad no
name no pictures just a voice everything
would you hit under the Doudna while
you're waiting for the response to this
yeah I was a grumpy grump that day when
it went out I was like who you know and
then I saw a couple of tweets and I
thought I got no one cares fine everyone
thinks that was sort of a Christmas
advert or something um see I was not
breaking it but those first two tweets
turned into a torrent and then a cascade
of tributes from her fans the website
was soon getting 4,000 hits a second
adil couldn't believe it Apple that long
you know being in the homes of that many
people and stuff like that but I'm
waiting for someone to send me about to
talk no more something that's not gonna
now I've got a special bonus rule from
Adele on how to separate work and home
that I think you're really gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing questions time to move
from just watching another video to
taking action in your life or business
and if you're feeling bold leave your
answers in the comments below here we go
question number one what's the impact
that you want to make number two how can
you better collaborate with others and
number three what instinct of yours do
you just need to go with
so there's work and there's home yes
separate those two oh yeah Oh
dynamite oh why is that so important to
you I'll tell you work I mean I don't
take me life to work either to gets too
emotional and to wish that that sounds
stupid because obviously I'm probably
the most emotional person with my heart
because I work I probably be but it's
more you know that's saying like oh
don't take your work home mine is more
like I've got a sweetie switch on to go
to work like my personalities are saying
about being in a headspace of being mum
to being me is like it's quite a big
shift and you have to be strict about
drawing those those boundaries yeah yeah
you know and you know and I'm really in
charge with everything that I do with my
career you know and I have a I have a
very firm stance on that whereas at home
I'm like I'm a hot chocolate
like I'm just a little puddle
if you want to learn how to make it as a
musician check the video right there
next to me I think you'll really enjoy
it continue to believe and I'll see you
there I want to tell you the most
important piece of information that
applies not only to your musical career
but your entire life and I've seen it
work and I've seen it not work